hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Ryan right
we're gonna check out several movie
clips of Avengers age of Ultron boy
howdy we don't want to be surprised
we just wanted all the clips to show us
as much as possible just like the
amazing spider-man 2 we need that we
need that because who really watches a
movie in the theaters anymore or when it
actually comes down the juice I prefer
all my entertainment in two minute
bite-sized chunks hmm maybe I should cut
out the juice Bart yeah you should might
be offensive
please yeah it would be yeah I don't
know why been in a better mood for this
very video so upset right I don't know
I'm not even sure why I mean I'm just
like in a randomly bitter mood whoa
whoa
pretty sure about vision but the vision
was fun I mean I loved I loved enough
playing him it was um you get to see him
born on on screen which I'll never get
to do again I hope and you know he's
supremely powerful and alright alright
so cool in all honesty I thought that
was pretty cool to see vision you know
so you're calling yeah is that what
they're calling him yeah the writers
made it I didn't know like I know him is
Jarvis and I'm not an expert evolves
into vision okay good I like the way
vision looks and it's kind of scary
because Jarvis is actually really
intelligent yeah so you put that in a
physical form and you have him like kind
of paired up with Ultron holy [ __ ] oh I
didn't know that I'm pretty sure he like
pairs up with Ultron it's not good at
all it's a bad that's a horrible thing
totebags it puts the Avengers in quite a
predicament hmm you know it's like Iron
Man probably couldn't handle that by
himself so he needs his come robbery
careful oh come oh I thought that was
intentional no you pervert Avengers age
of Ultron clip number 12
well God we're heading under the
overpass I've got no show
all right now a little dish
damn that was pretty cool that's pretty
cool first thought was Matrix Reloaded
but then as it progressed I was like you
know I'm digging this music actually I
like how much she was going through
Chinatown they kind of had a little
Chinese music going on and this is a
cool clip I mean this only proves to me
exactly what I was hoping and expecting
was that hey there's gonna be action in
this movies okay I just realized why I'm
bitter or even mean quitting cigarettes
dude that's a symptom of withdrawal
you're angry [ __ ] man yeah [ __ ] you
dude dude okay you guys might not know
this oh I've been chained smoking for
the past like 14 years which I started
when I was nine it's been a couple years
I've cut back a lot I'm gonna do the
weeding off thing so instead of chain
smoking a pack every two days I'm down
to three cigarettes a day and it's the
hardest thing I've done in a long time
hey at least you didn't get to pack and
a minutes that's a heavy business yeah
you could have been worse I was almost
at a packer day so let's uh let's
continue this journey I thought I'd
share some personal life struggles with
you guys right now
you know with Captain America I like how
this clip shows us that that moment when
he's in danger that Ultron might kill
him Scarlett Johansson we'll make sure
everything's okay and you'll escape just
fine although I've acknowledged where
the bitterness is coming from and as he
gone away oh no I mean it's just it's
not a very substantial clip it's like
yeah she's gonna get him his shield and
he's gonna punch out wrong with the
shield all right clip number 13 boy
howdy
whoa
Wow
don't look at me
yeah
it's safe you'll never leave everyone
huh you didn't finish what were you
napping you're like these all look a lot
better on the big screen that was a
really cool clip actually Gaza
ya know was cool it was red oh I'm going
through a journey of emotions right here
watching the Marvel phase movies in the
exact order of release date I'm now
gonna be starting Thor the dark world
tonight I'm starting to feel like my
spirits get uplifted because that clip
when she dropped from the car I
completely forgot there's like other
Avengers who can fly cuz like no they
she are you gonna die he looks like he
failed it was a shocking moment for me
yeah never thought it showed up I was
like oh yeah there's like 16 other
superheroes in this movie well it's
always nice when superhero movies check
back into the fact that there are just
regular people in the middle of all this
you know and I like how that moment
really does establish that they need
each other
in this time of crisis yeah that they
can't do it alone that they have to work
together it makes them a team a
necessary team mm-hmm yeah these videos
are getting better
yeah I'm lifting my mood right now
should have started off with this these
are all you need to help stop you from
smoking one last one
you're wondering why I'm looking such
sorry Jeff Bridges was talking just that
Jerry has back pain that's the problem
that he has you're wondering why you
can't look inside my head sometimes it's
hard
but sooner or later every man shows
himself
I'm sure they do
but you needed something more than a man
that's why you let's start take the
scepter I didn't expect but I saw Starks
fear
I knew it with control him make him
self-destruct everyone creates the thing
they dread men of peace create engines
of war invaders create Avengers people
create smaller people children have lost
the word they're children designed to
supplant them to help them is that why
you've come to end the Avengers I've
come to save the world
but also yeah yeah I'm down the first
time I saw Ultron's personality I was
turned off now that I'm looking at a
second clip I'm actually digging it yeah
because it's like he could have just
been some typical robot kind of like how
the trailers sort of advertising as like
oh he's just a robot with a menacing
personality but to see how he sort of
has like a three-dimensional human
personality about everything and sort of
like Tony Stark's sense of humor which
would make sense was Danny created him
to have that level of like person
ability is kind of funny like Rick if
you like I think he was faking it when
he said he couldn't remember the name
children no I'm Aiman bloody forget that
would make me a lot less scared of him
if he forgot that worked maybe it
suggests that they're less than
important to him and makes him more
scary interesting Wow Wow
that's the power of writing it's open to
interpretation well that's an artificial
intelligence kind of a thing yeah you
know people lose words all the time I
think it's cool that they they're you
know giving him that angle of like no no
no I'm saving the world I dig it I'm
excited to see the film in a couple of
weeks he wants it back yeah
Oh bored anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects Jerry has a playlist on
this channel called reasons to G area
where he does movie reviews you know I'm
glad we watched all four clips because I
felt myself go through bitterness
through joy through oh yeah in a few
days I'm gonna be watching this movie
and a character arc I had a whole
character arc you know I should write a
90 minutes screenplay it takes place on
a real regional one shot yeah you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
get a certain amount of your product
placement what
I'm gonna combine shoutouts here because
these guys didn't say much
Rocco Cinelli said love your channel
keep up the great work
but Kier too we said dude if you give me
a shout-out I will [ __ ] on your man tits
that's not an incentive to give you a
shot like I know it certainly is now
here's why I you're [ __ ] then here
is why I put these two shoutouts
together I want them to compete with
each other Rocco but Kier is willing to
[ __ ] on my chest
what are you Wilma do Rocco
it doesn't matter now they've already
both gotten the shoutouts I wanted to
see all of them to prove their level of
love for me you know Rocco is the name
of a really popular porn star he does
really graphic pornography you know like
slaps the woman and [ __ ] and like you
know does like like clip the vaginas and
like those metal I was like bondage
stuff
yeah like bondage stuff S&M stuff but
Bakir he shits on people to each their
own so Rocco are you as dirty as the
Cure I'm starting to lose faith in you
man sir I was faith in you
Bakir don't you come over this is for my
big here only this is for you big here
let's put Rocco and Baqir in the same
room with a ride